Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Quanti di voi conoscono Iron Man?
Come sapete, è un uomo che indossa
una sorta di armatura
che lo rende più forte.
Per meglio dire, indossa un esoscheletro.
Ecco, io sono qua oggi
per parlarvi
di "esoscheletri",
cioè robot indossabili.
Quindi vi parlerò di fantascienza, oggi?
No, non proprio:
ci sono tanti centri di ricerca
che studiano e progettano
questo tipo di tecnologia.
Tant'è che, in un futuro
non troppo lontano,
potrebbe diventare qualcosa
veramente di quotidiano,
e quindi potremmo, magari
tra qualche anno, aprire il vostro armadio
e trovare, oltre alla giacca,
il nostro esoscheletro personale.
Ecco, ma com’è fatto un esoscheletro?
Abbiamo detto che
è un robot indossabile.
È indossabile perché, diciamo,
accoglie le nostre articolazioni,
e ci consente di assecondare
il movimento, un po' come un vestito;
robot, perché fa fatica al posto nostro!
Tra gli esperti di questa tecnologia
c'è il laboratorio
di robotica percettiva, PERCRO,
dell'Università Scuola Superiore
Sant'Anna di Pisa,
che ha un'esperienza di oltre 20 anni
nello studio di questa tecnologia.
Recentemente, varie idee
e brevetti nati dalla ricerca
hanno portato
alla costituzione di una spin-off,
ovvero un'azienda che mette sul mercato
i risultati di idee nate dalla ricerca.
La nostra azienda si chiama
"Wearable Robotics",
cioè "Robotica Indossabile".
E "Kinetek" ne è la divisione medica.
Ma a che cosa serve un esoscheletro?
Prendiamo il settore medico: un
esoscheletro serve nella riabilitazione.
Come molti di voi sapranno,
la popolazione media mondiale
sta invecchiando,
quindi vuol dire, purtroppo,
che ci sono molte più persone
che hanno bisogno di aiuto, di cure.
Quello che accade, per esempio,
se andiamo a vedere gli ictus,
pensate che in un anno 15 milioni
di persone sono colpite da ictus.
I due terzi di questi sopravvivono
e possono intraprendere
un percorso di riabilitazione.
Per esempio la fisioterapia,
che è un tipo di percorso
che consente di recuperare la mobilità,
per esempio delle articolazioni,
dei muscoli,
la capacità di deambulare,
cioè di camminare.
Supponiamo quindi di voler fare
la riabilitazione per l'arto superiore
con il nostro ultimo esoscheletro,
da poco sviluppato,
che abbiamo battezzato ALEX.
ALEX può aiutare il paziente
in modi diversi.
Per esempio, il fisioterapista
può impostare il robot
in modo da guidare il paziente
nei movimenti che deve fare,
così come il fisioterapista
guiderebbe il paziente.
Il vantaggio è che
se dobbiamo fare un esercizio
per un po' di tempo, per qualche giorno,
ecco che il fisioterapista
imposta ALEX una volta
e la macchina dopo fa da sé.
Il vantaggio è che,
a parità di fisioterapisti,
possiamo aiutare più persone.
Attenzione però, non fa tutto il robot:
lo scopo finale è che la persona
possa recuperare le sue capacità motorie.
Quindi si dice che il robot,
ALEX, coopera con il paziente,
e questo livello
di cooperazione è variabile.
In particolare decresce nel tempo.
Quindi, all'inizio il robot
ci metterà molto del suo,
e il paziente potrà metterci poco.
Man mano che si progredisce,
che si va avanti nel tempo,
il robot dà un contributo,
una cooperazione sempre più bassa:
nel frattempo, il paziente
dà un contributo sempre maggiore,
finché non riusciamo
a recuperare la capacità motoria.
Un altro aspetto interessante
degli esoscheletri
è che possono essere integrati
con tecnologie di realtà virtuale.
Cioè, per esempio,
possiamo indossare un caschetto,
e interagire con un ambiente virtuale
facendo dei semplici giochi, delle azioni:
stringere la mano a un avatar, o fare
semplici giochi detti "serious game",
cioè "giochi seri", letteralmente,
perché sono dei giochi
che non hanno uno scopo solo ludico
e basta, di intrattenimento,
ma tendono, invogliano, stimolano
la persona che li sta facendo
a fare quel determinato tipo di esercizio
di cui ha bisogno.
Infatti, come potete immaginare,
in tutto questo
c'è una fortissima componente psicologica.
Noi lavoriamo da diversi anni,
collaboriamo con l'Azienda Ospedaliera
Universitaria Pisana
e conosciamo molte persone
che purtroppo si ritrovano,
da un giorno all'altro, a non poter più
utilizzare il proprio braccio
come facevano fino a poco tempo prima.
Quello che accade a questi uomini
e a queste donne
è che quasi dimenticano
di usare questo braccio,
e questo ha delle conseguenze
su tutta la loro vita quotidiana:
basti pensare a doversi lavare,
vestirsi, il comportamento a tavola
- hai una mano
che però non puoi utilizzare...
Ecco, la nostra vision,
quello che vogliamo fare noi,
è dare una mano a queste persone.
Ma non siamo i soli a farlo:
nel mondo ci sono diversi, abbiamo detto,
centri di ricerca e laboratori
che sviluppano esoscheletri.
Pensate che esistono
esoscheletri per le gambe
che sono in grado
di far camminare nuovamente
le persone che sono sulla sedia a rotelle.
Però, come vi ho detto anche prima,
è una tecnologia
ancora parzialmente immatura,
e che è ancora in fase di sviluppo.
Per esempio, uno degli aspetti
di cui vorrei parlarvi
è il fatto che molti degli esoscheletri
che oggi esistono
montano, per funzionare,
dei motori elettrici che sono montati
in corrispondenza delle articolazioni
- sul gomito, sulla spalla, ecc.-
Lo svantaggio di questo
è che questi esoscheletri
possono diventare un po' ingombranti
e quindi non consentire
a chi li sta indossando
di avere quella capacità di movimento
che avrebbe la persona
in maniera naturale:
parliamo di “vestito”, però
se diventa eccessivamente ingombrante
diventa un po' difficile
fare determinati tipi di movimento.
Ecco, uno dei nostri contributi
in questo senso
è il fatto di montare questi motori,
che servono ad azionare il robot,
da un'altra parte:
in uno zaino, che viene indossato
dal paziente.
E questi motori sono collegati
con dei piccoli cavi
che arrivano alle articolazioni
– gomito, spalla ecc.-
e permettono il movimento.
Il vantaggio è che le parti mobili,
quindi l'esoscheletro,
è molto snello, è molto leggero,
e quindi ecco
che possiamo, effettivamente,
effettuare tutta quella serie di movimenti
che normalmente saremmo abituati
a fare con il nostro braccio,
e che non potremmo fare
con soluzioni più ingombranti.
Ecco, adesso vi faccio vedere
un breve video
sul nostro ultimo esoscheletro ALEX.
(Applausi)
Questo appunto, come abbiamo detto,
riguarda la riabilitazione.
Però in realtà ci sono
altri utilizzi, altri scopi
per cui possono essere utili
gli esoscheletri,
ad esempio quello dell'assistenza.
Per esempio, supponiamo che io debba
sollevare un carico da 10-15 chili.
Se lo faccio
indossando un esoscheletro,
posso sollevare questo carico
senza sentire sforzo,
perché ci pensa l'esoscheletro.
Pensate quindi al vantaggio
che ci può essere, per esempio,
per gli operai del settore edilizio!
Questi, durante la loro vita lavorativa,
sollevano e movimentano carichi
di grande entità e per lunghi tempi.
Quindi accade che purtroppo, dopo anni,
insorgono malattie
dell'apparato muscolo-scheletrico.
Questo genere di malattie
potrebbe essere evitato
se la persona indossasse l'esoscheletro.
Farebbe lo sforzo per lui
comunque garantendogli
quell'ampiezza di movimento
che gli è necessaria
per compiere quel determinato tipo
di operazione.
Ecco, questo tipo di idea, attualmente,
ha un piccolo svantaggio,
o se vogliamo un limite, che è quello
dell'autonomia energetica.
Ovvero, questi esoscheletri
possono funzionare,
per una certa quantità di tempo
– per qualche ora, in generale –
dopodiché, un po' come
i vostri telefonini, vanno ricaricati.
Ecco, vediamo di capire come abbiamo
cercato di affrontare il problema.
Io prendo questo libro, e lo voglio
sollevare, portare in alto.
Faccio questa cosa qua, niente di più.
Cosa ho fatto?
Ho speso energia,
ho fatto uno sforzo fisico,
ho dato dell'energia al libro
per portarlo in questa posizione.
Se lo riporto indietro,
faccio nientemeno che questo.
Adesso, se voglio ricominciare da capo,
ecco che se lo voglio riportare in alto
devo di nuovo spendere energia,
fare uno sforzo fisico.
E siamo arrivati qua.
Però, se ci pensiamo, in realtà il libro
nella fase di discesa
potrebbe fare da solo:
io lo sto frenando, l'energia
per andar giù ce l'ha!
Ecco, ma allora ci siamo detti,
qual è l'idea?
Nella fase di discesa, in cui io
ho questa energia che butto via,
invece di buttarla via la recupero,
la metto da parte, in un serbatoio.
Un serbatoio di energia
a che cosa mi serve?
La prossima volta che voglio sollevare
il libro non devo spendere energia,
ma prendo l'energia dal serbatoio
in cui l'ho messa prima,
nella fase di discesa.
Complicato?
Se ci pensate, un esempio lo abbiamo
sotto gli occhi tutti i giorni!
Quanti di voi conoscono questa lampada?
Alzate le mani?
Moltissimi, quasi tutti, ce l'avete a casa
o ce l'avete in ufficio.
Ecco: se ci fate caso,
questa lampada ha delle molle.
Cosa sono?
Il serbatoio di energia
di cui vi parlavo prima.
Vediamo di capire come funziona:
io prendo questa lampada,
fisso la base, la posso spostare
in qualsiasi posizione io desideri,
e la lampada – mi accorgo
che effettivamente
resta sempre in quella posizione.
Si chiama "equilibrio indifferente":
vuol dire che la lampada e le molle
si scambiano continuamente
una certa quantità di energia.
In particolare, quindi,
se io voglio andare in alto,
ecco che le molle danno energia
alla lampada, quindi si accorciano;
viceversa, quando io voglio scendere,
portare giù la lampada,
prendo quell'energia lì
e la immagazzino nelle molle,
e quindi si allungano.
Ecco, ma.. visto tutto questo,
ci siamo chiesti:
ma ci può essere utile, ci può
dare una mano per i nostri esoscheletri,
per la nostra tecnologia,
possiamo innovare?
Ecco, noi crediamo che innovare
sia farsi sempre domande,
non smettere mai di farsi domande,
chiedersi il perché delle cose,
ma tutte, qualsiasi:
fare come i bambini, che chiedono:
“Ma perché? Ma perché? Ma perché?”
Bisogna fare così, non bisogna
accontentarsi di quelli che ti dicono:
"Si è sempre fatto così, va bene,
lascia stare, fa così, punto."
No, bisogna guardare oltre.
Pensare, farsi sempre domande.
E noi ci siamo detti:
possiamo fare qualcosa del genere
nei nostri esoscheletri?
Sì.
Non è banale, ci sono dei brevetti,
d'accordo; però si può fare.
Ecco, ma che significa tutto questo
in parole povere?
Che se io torno all'esempio
dell'operaio del settore edilizio,
non solo se questo solleva il suo carico
da 15 kg lo fa senza sforzo,
ma lo fa e lo muove come crede
senza che io consumi energia elettrica,
nei motori dell'esoscheletro.
E quindi voi capite che siamo partiti
dall'autonomia energetica,
e arriviamo a una tecnologia,
a un brevetto, che ci consente di avere
un notevole aumento dell'autonomia
energetica di questi dispositivi.
Ecco, recentemente, stiamo sviluppando,
stiamo portando a termine
il progetto di un esoscheletro completo,
cioè dotato di braccia e gambe
per l'assistenza
- quindi sollevamento carichi -
basato su questo principio.
Questo principio che appunto consente
un'elevata autonomia energetica,
questo grosso serbatoio di energia
perché in qualche modo
mettiamo delle molle,
un po' come sulla lampada,
nel nostro esoscheletro,
che però sono regolabili:
ci sono dei piccoli motori,
nell'esoscheletro, che consentono-
che solo quando vogliamo
cambiare il carico
vanno utilizzati per regolare le molle.
Altrimenti, non c'è consumo energetico.
E quindi, parlando di energia,
con questa idea di energia.
E sempre a proposito di energia,
è proprio grazie all'energia
che il nostro team ha messo
in questo progetto, in questa idea,
che abbiamo avuto l'onore, a fine 2013,
di vincere il Premio Gaetano Marzotto
"Impresa del futuro",
che consiste in una somma di 250.000 Euro,
per finanziare il progetto,
e un contributo formativo per le persone
a supporto - nella gestione dell'azienda.
Quindi noi andiamo avanti,
nel nostro lavoro,
con l'idea costante
che la tecnologia
può davvero aiutare
a migliorare le nostre vite.
Grazie!
(Applausi)